where would trees or once found
throughout all of Westeros
they have leaves with five points and
their sap is the color of blood and
their bark is smooth and white as ivory
most of the where woods we see in our
story have faces carved into their
trunks in a dance with dragons blood
Raven tells bran that the children
carved the faces into the where woods to
help beginning greenseers learn to use
their powers a green seer can see the
past and the present when looking
through the eyes of a weirwood where
woods are said to be eternal if not cut
down their wood is excellent and very
expensive due to their rarity building
material taken from where woods will
never rot the oldest stories that we
have claimed that the children worship
the old gods the where woods themselves
in general I have thought that the claim
that the where woods themselves were
gods was erroneous no true gods existed
within those trees none other than the
green cedars who watched through them
but what if the where woods being gods
was closer to the truth than I initially
believed it is said that no lie can be
told in the presence of a weirwood tree
where woods are used to bear witness to
important ceremonies human followers
believe that the old gods watched
through the phases there are also
bloodier traditions stories of blood
offerings made to the trees then a long
cruel winter fell said cirbar Thomas the
white knife froze hard and even the
Firth was icing up the winds came
howling from the north and drove them
slavers inside to huddle round their
fires and whilst they warmed themselves
the new king come down on them Brandon
Stark this was Adric Snow beards
great-grandson him that men called ice
eyes he took the Wolf's den back
stripped the slavers naked
and gave them to the slaves he'd found
chained up in the dungeons it said they
hung their entrails in the branches of
the Hart tree as an offering to the gods
the old gods not these new ones from the
south you're seven don't know winter and
winter don't know them and what is to be
made of all the bones found in blood
Ravens cave evidence of this tradition
being continued amongst the children of
the forest to this day in brans vision
of the past he can see a woman sacrifice
a man before a weirwood tree and as the
blood spills into the ground bran can
taste it in his mouth it is said that
the children of the forest gathered in
their greatest numbers on the Isle of
faces to bring about the breaking of the
world which shattered the arm of Dorne
some say that a thousand men were
sacrificed before the ware woods and in
the darkest stories of course it is said
that the children murdered their own
young before the heart trees what is it
about the trees that grants them the
power to destroy entire land bridges and
create giant marshes where woods are
obviously beyond the normal trees of the
world they are unique distinguished
special we can assume that they have
existed for as long as the children have
perhaps longer and leave said in a dance
with dragons that the children have
existed for a thousand thousand years
the children of the forest and the trees
seemed to have formed a symbiotic
relationship the werewolves depend on
the children for protection and bloody
sacrifice in return the children are
granted powers over the earth and in
afterlife within the weirwood net the
initial conflict in Westeros was not
between mankind and the children of the
forest
it was between mankind and the where
woods the massive system of trees
throughout Westeros connected by a
complex collection of roots deep within
the earth if the where woods were
connected throughout Westeros by their
roots perhaps with a massive enough
blood sacrifice
those roots could move shake even and
destroy parts of the world the land
bridge connecting door in two S's was
tiny compared to the marshlands it makes
sense why the children succeeded at
breaking the arm but failed at
separating the marshlands mankind
attacked the weirwood net the moment
they put an axe into a weirwood tree
each weirwood tree is like an ant
individually it cannot survive this is
why no tree was ever able to be grown in
the Eyrie
far from the roots of the earth but
together the weirwood trees of Westeros
form a super organism capable of
incredible feats perhaps even
intelligence if each where would in
Westeros was even slightly aware the
connection between each beacon of
awareness to the next would multiply the
cognitive ability exponentially what if
the weirwood net is fully aware what if
the weirwood net has a will of its own
what if it is owed a debt what if it
needs to be fed the question has been
asked why when a pact be made between
men and the children when men were
winning why were the first men so
willing to abandon their own gods for
the trees and participate in blood
sacrifice to sate their hunger is it
possible that the children fear the
woods their gods the concept of fearing
of God is not a new one is it possible
that they infected humans with this same
fear the information that was the
catalyst for this infection would had to
have been very convincing but if
convincing enough evidence existed it
would explain why mankind agreed to
adopt these gods and feed them until
they didn't of course it is evident that
the sacrifice to the weirwood trees is
no longer common amongst men but a pact
was made and if the pact included
sacrifice to the weirwood trees then
mankind is in violation of the
Packt I had assumed that the children of
the forest created the others for the
sole purpose of revenge but what if
there was another purpose to feed the
trees and once the others had swept over
all of Westeros and the world lay in an
eternal dark and aware woods had drink
the blood of men the others retreated
into the land of always winter slept for
thousands of years but mankind never
knew that the children created the
others they besieged their help in
building the wall but what evidence do
we have that the wall truly repels the
others the two whites in book one were
brought through the wall and awoke on
the other side cold hands claims he
could not pass but can we really be
certain that he is telling the truth
could the children have simply helped
mankind built the wall to keep them
content the children would have known
the whole time that the wall was useless
against the others
who were said to be able to manipulate
ice in ways that mortals can hardly
comprehend it has been eight thousand
years since the trees were last fed in
great numbers but now the others are
coming again to feed the trees
[Music]
you